The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Hello.
So there's almost certainly
no need to show this,
but the good news is this
is the last time I'll ever
show a slide like this.
It'll never happen again.
At least not to this crowd.
So you can all rest assured
this is the last time you'll
see something like this.
Any questions on this,
everybody's happy?
Those are two separate
questions, I guess.
Any questions on this?
OK, good.
So today I want to
finish up talking
about Fourier transforms by
comparing a lot of stuff we've
already done.
So there's nothing new today.
This is intended,
if anything, to be
a bit of a review
in light of things
that might happen tomorrow.
And also just to make
things look simpler.
Now, the best way to
make things look simpler
is to start with something that
looks incredibly complicated.
OK, so this is my thing
that looks very complicated.
This is simply a summary
of the transforms
that we've talked about today.
We've talked about four of them.
And the point of
the slide is first,
it looks a little complicated.
But much more importantly,
by the end of the hour,
it's supposed to
look very simple.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could we
increase the volume?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Could we
increase the volume a bit?
Well, I know that
I can shout more.
And if they notice me, they'll
turn the volume up, too.
So I will try to shout more.
So if I don't, please
tell me to do so.
So the idea, then, is to try
to look for some structure.
Not only within one
of the transforms,
but also across all
of the transforms.
And to start this off,
let's just think about it
at the most basic level.
What were the kinds of
signals that we thought about?
The kinds of signals
that we thought
about when we did DT
Fourier series, DT Fourier
transforms, CT Fourier series,
and CT Fourier transforms?
The kinds of signals
look different, right?
So in the top ones,
we had discrete time.
In the bottom ones, we
have continuous time.
In the left we have
things that are periodic.
In the right we had things
that were not periodic.
Four different kinds of signals.
Not surprising there would
be four different kinds
of transforms.
An interesting thing happens if
you look at the Fourier domain.
I haven't switched
around the order.
It was DT Fourier, DT
Fourier transform, CT series,
CT transform.
It's still that.
I've drawn a sort of
iconic view of how
we would draw a picture of the
Fourier transform of interest.
Where is discrete?
So discrete in the
previous picture--
which was a picture of time--
NNTT.
Where was discrete
in this picture?
Up.
Where is discrete
in this picture?
Left, that's weird.
Where is periodic
in this picture?
Left.
Where is periodic
in this picture?
Is there a periodic
Top.
Why do you say top?
Ah, unit circle!
Unit circle is periodic.
So there's discreteness and
periodicity in both pictures,
but they're not
at the same place.
Well, that's kind of
interesting, right?
Somehow, discrete
and periodic map
to things like
discrete and periodic,
but they don't map directly.
That's kind of interesting.
So part of the goal
today is to try
to get to the bottom of that.
To understand why that's true.
You already know a lot about how
different transformations are
related.
So let's think of
a simple example
of the relation between Fourier
series and Fourier transforms.
Imagine that we have one of
those signals that was periodic
in time, continuous in time.
Then there'd be a
Fourier series--
represented this way.
So I'd end up with a
Fourier series that has
a bunch of coefficients, a, k.
Can somebody tell me, what
would the Fourier transform
look like?
Fourier transform--
are you allowed
to take the Fourier transform
of a periodic thing?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could we take the
same thing with impulses?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Take the
same thing with impulses.
OK, I like lots of those words.
Could you put them together
in slightly a different order?
Where should I put the impulses?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: At the k omega not.
DENNIS FREEMAN: At
the k omega not.
How do you get that?
That's exactly right.
How'd you get that?
AUDIENCE: Because
the [INAUDIBLE]..
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
there's some kind
of a relationship between the
k's, in the ak's, and frequency
that ought to be
represented as an impulse,
is what you're saying?
One way you can see that
is to take the Fourier
transform of this expression.
What would you get if you
took the Fourier transform
of x of t, x of j omega?
That's pretty easy.
What would you get if you took
the Fourier transform of a sum?
What do you always
get when you take
the Fourier transfer of a sum?
The sum of the Fourier
transforms, right?
It's within your operator.
That's one of the most
powerful reasons we like it.
So sum of the functions, take
the transform of each one.
Add them back up.
How do you take the Fourier
transform of e to the j omega
not t?
What's the Fourier
transform? e to the j omega
not t transforms to what?
Fourier transform-- impulse.
So how do I know that?
So impulse-- what
else, anything?
Am I done?
Where should I put the impulse?
What should I put--
how should I indicate
where I put it?
So I need to say omega minus
omega not, or something
like that, right?
So how do I know that?
And am I done?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Multiply by 2 pi.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Multiply by 2 pi.
And a good way to
do that is just
to memorize an absurd
number of equations, right?
Let's think about how
you would remember that.
So if you wanted to take the
Fourier transform of anything,
right?
You would say, h of j omega
is some integral of anything e
to the minus j
omega t dt, right?
What happens if I plug x of
t equals e to the j omega
not t into this expression?
Can you close the integral?
I mean, that's the way
you would do it, right?
I want to take the Fourier
transform of e to the j omega
not t.
You stick it in the formula,
and it should come out, right?
So how many of you can
integrate this function?
No one, good.
That's good, because
I can't either.
What's hard about
integrating that function?
That was a much easier
question, right?
Can you integrate
was a hard question.
Well, maybe not.
It's binary.
What's difficult
about integrating
that function of time?
What if I try to integrate
e to the j omega not
t e to the minus j omega t dt?
What's difficult about
integrating that function?
What do we do when we see
these sorts of things--
e to the j omega not t?
How do you think
about e to the--
complex exponential.
You can name out things like
Euler's equation, right?
So e to the j omega not t--
you might want to say,
well, that's the same thing
as cosine omega not t
plus j sine omega not t.
If I took just the first
term-- cosine omega not t,
does it have a
Laplace transform?
Doesn't have a Laplace
transform, hmm.
How about a Fourier transform?
Why does it have a Fourier
transform and not a Laplace
transform?
So Laplace transforms-- there's
only a Laplace transform
if there's some kind of
a multiplicative kernel--
e to the minus st--
that has some values that
make the integral converge.
There's no value of s for
which e to the j omega
not t will converge.
The amplitude of e to
the j omega not t--
the real part has an amplitude
that fluctuates like this
and never decays.
Goes on forever and
ever in both directions.
There's no exponential
function that you
can multiply times that
function to make it converge.
There is no Laplace transform.
Is there a Fourier transform?
Yeah.
What's different?
What makes us be able to
do a Fourier transform
and not a Laplace transform?
Delta functions.
We never write a
Laplace transform
with a delta function, ever.
If you write on your exam h of s
is some function of delta of s,
that's definitely wrong, right?
We just never do that.
We're much more liberal
about using delta functions
in Fourier transforms.
That's one of the
reasons they're powerful.
And one of the ways you
can think about that
is that delta functions
are easy to integrate.
That's not quite enough.
The other thing that's
important to realize
is that we've got
this integral here--
it's either going to
be zero or infinity.
There's going to be
certain values of omega
that when we multiply
this together,
we're going to get something
that goes on and on forever
and ever and never decays.
That's going to
give us infinity.
And there's going
to be other values
that the long-term integral's
going to go to zero.
And that information is
summarized by the impulses,
right?
So if we choose omega not--
if we choose omega
to be omega not--
then when we do the
integral, which comes out
a function of omega, we're
going to get something
that goes to infinity.
OK?
The easy way to think about that
is to do the inverse Fourier
transform, right?
The inverse Fourier
transform is x of t
is 1 over 2 pi in the integral
x of j omega e to the j omega t
d omega.
Now, if we put the delta
function in this, it's easy.
Because the delta
function over here--
if we say that--
it's x over here and
it's h over there.
But who cares?
That should have been x.
If we put over there
that the x of j
omega is 2 pi delta
omega minus omega not,
then we can see that the
function of the delta
is just to sift out a
particular value of e
to the j omega t,
the one at omega not.
And the 2 pi's obvious, too.
The 2 pi came from the
1 over 2 pi, right?
We had to have a 2 pi out
front so that the 1 over 2 pi
killed it.
OK, anyway-- so
the idea, then, is
that simply by taking the
Fourier transform of this,
we can get an expression
for the Fourier transform.
And that tells us something
about the great utility
of using impulses, right?
Because we use impulses
in the Fourier transform,
we can represent
a lot more signals
than we could have represented
in the Laplace transform.
That's one of the
utilities of a Fourier.
And there's a big relationship
between the Fourier series
and the Fourier transform.
So in particular, if we have a
signal that's periodic in time,
it'll have both a
series and a transform.
The transform is a bunch
of delta functions weighted
by the Fourier series
coefficients and 2 pi.
And what that says
is, had we been
willing to put in
impulses to begin with,
we would never have had
to define the series.
We did the series just
because it was easy.
Convergence issues
were more clear.
But if we had been willing to
think about delta functions
in the transforms-- which
would have been an extremely
foreign concept coming
straight from Laplace, where
you would never see that.
Had we been willing to
accept delta functions
in the transforms
from the outset,
we never would
have needed series.
So the relationship between
series and transforms
has to do with the fact
that the series represents
periodic signals.
Periodic signals go on forever.
There's never a
Laplace transform,
and that means that--
there's never a
Laplace transform.
That means the Fourier transform
has a bunch of delta functions
in it, OK?
OK, so what I want
to do, then, is
think through
other relationships
that are on this table.
And in particular, I
want to think about them
by thinking about the underlying
structure of the signals.
So think about having
DTFS, DTFT, CTFS, and CTFT.
So what I want to do is
think about the relationships
among those four transforms
by thinking about how
they differ in time, right?
So the top guys are
discrete in time.
The bottom guys are
continuous in time.
The left guys are
periodic in time.
The right ones are
aperiodic in time.
So what I want to do
to think about how
they relate to each other,
is think about a base case.
Think about a signal that's
down here-- aperiodic CT.
And think about what you would
have to do to the signal,
and therefore what would you
have to do to the transform.
If you wanted to move this way--
I'll do that one first.
If you move up--
I'll do that one second.
Or if you move that way--
I'll do that one third.
So really, the rest of the hour
is just doing three examples.
Well, four examples.
What's the transform
of a base case?
Then what would happen as
I move through this table?
OK, everybody's
with the game plan?
So here's my base case.
I want to think about the
Fourier transform of a signal,
x of t, that's a triangle.
We could calculate the
Fourier transform just
from the definition.
That's trivial, right?
Good way, bad way.
Good way.
Smile.
Better.
OK, bad way--
I can think of a
better way to do it.
What's a better way to do it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
one way is to think
about turning straight lines
into constants via derivatives
and integrals and
stuff like that.
That's a very good way.
Can somebody think
of a different way?
That'll work, it'll be fine.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is that the
convolution of two square
pulses?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Convolution
of two square pulses,
that's wonderful.
So a different way we can do it
is to convolve a square pulse
with a square pulse.
That's particularly
good for this example,
because a square pulse is
one of our canonical forms.
So if we think about
what's the Fourier
transform of a square pulse?
We all know that it's something
that has the form sine
omega over omega.
So all we really need to do
is fill in the constants.
Filling in the
constants is easy,
because we know the
moment theorems.
The moment theorem
says that whatever
the area is under
this curve, it has
to be the height
of that curve at 0.
Whatever is the area
under this curve,
it has to be the
height of that one.
Except that you have
to divide by 2 pi,
because the annoying
2 pi factor.
The annoying 2 pi
factor is something
that's in the inverse
transform and not
in the Fourier transform.
That makes it asymmetric.
So in order to choose the
constants-- the area under this
is 1, so that height must be 1.
The area under this,
by magic, turns
into the area of that
triangle, which is 2 pi.
Divide by 2 pi is 1.
So that means that this
frequency must be 2 pi
in order to make
that constant be 1.
So we're done.
So we know, then, that the
transform of this signal,
which is the convolution
of this signal with itself,
is just the product of
this function with itself.
Convolution in time maps to
multiplication in frequency.
OK?
So that's the base case.
Now what I want
to think about is
how I would march
through the table.
That's my case down here.
So what I want to do
first is think about,
how would I convert
that this way?
And what's the implication
for that conversion
in terms of time, and
in terms of frequency?
So one way to think about the
transformation from a transform
to a series--
you can only series with
things that are periodic.
The transformation that
we talked about in class
was periodic extension.
So you think about taking
the base case, which
was a single triangle
wave, and turning it
into a sequence
of triangle waves.
There's lots of ways
to think about that.
But the way I want to motivate
is to think about it--
well, no, backing up.
So if we think
about the triangle
wave and transformation and
make it into a periodic triangle
wave, we could just
substitute this
into the definition
of transform.
That's ugly, why?
For the same reason
that one was ugly.
What's ugly about this?
The signal goes on and
on and on and on and on.
There will be
certain frequencies
where it'll blow up.
Those will be infinity.
There will be other
frequencies where it is 0.
There could be frequencies
where it's minus infinity,
and those are the
only three options.
Since it goes on and
on and on and on,
if it's anything
different from 0,
it has to be either
infinity or minus infinity.
It's going to be a train of
impulses for the same reason
that thing was some kind
of a train of impulses.
So we want to have a good
way of thinking about it.
I told you one way
to think about this--
by taking the inverse transform.
This is a little harder
to guess the transforms,
so you can verify
it with the inverse.
But you can form
this by thinking
about convolving the base
waveform with an impulse train.
So what if I had
an impulse train?
So I'm-- oh, it's
on the next slide.
What if I had an
impulse train like so?
If I think about having
an impulse train,
if I had the base waveform and
an appropriate impulse train,
how could I manufacture the
signal of interest, which
is this periodic extension?
So if I have these
two signals, what
would I do to get that signal?
Convolve.
So if I knew the
transform of this,
which I do because this is the
base case which we just did.
If I knew the transform
of the base case,
and if I knew the transform
of the impulse train--
impulse train is something
that goes to function of time.
0-- let's say that
they're separated by t.
Let's say each one
has a height of 1.
What's the Fourier transform
of an impulse train?
I can see you're all on
the edge of your seats.
How do you find the Fourier
transform of an impulse train?
OK, ask your neighbor.
So how do you find the Fourier
transform of an impulse train?
Look it up in the tables!
Boo, hiss.
How do you find the Fourier
transform of an impulse train?
Is there anything easy
about an impulse train?
What a horrendous thing, right?
It has an infinite
number of impulses, yuck.
Each impulse is
horribly misbehaved.
How would I find the
Fourier transform
of a train of impulses?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if you
actually just plug
that in to the
formula, then you get
different exponents
and like, [INAUDIBLE],,
and then, since there's
negative infinity to infinity,
they add up to the [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So you're
saying that somehow I
should stick it into--
so I'm thinking about finding
the Fourier transform by going
back to the direct formula.
So if I put an infinite train of
impulses here, what would I do?
So I'd have a sum
of delta of t minus,
say, n times t sum over n e
to the minus j omega t dt.
That's a good step.
So now, what I might
do is interchange
the order, because that's
what everybody does, right?
And it's a little dicey
doing that, right?
You're always safe to do that
if the integrand is absolutely
summable.
That's not precisely
absolutely summable.
Everybody knows what
absolutely summable means?
So it means if you
took the absolute value
and you summed it
over all of time,
you would get something
less than infinity.
That's not quite the
truth here, right?
So some of the sums in Fourier
series and Fourier transforms
can be hard, OK?
But throwing
caution to the wind,
we would probably get
something like that.
And then we could say,
well, that just samples it.
We could sample this
thing at t equals nt.
So that would be e to
the minus j omega nt.
Then I end up summing
a large number
of complex exponentials--
large being infinite.
It's kind of ugly.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you
now [INAUDIBLE]..
So I could split
this into two sums--
n less than 0, and a similar
sum-- n bigger than 0.
And then throw in the 0
term, just for good measure.
AUDIENCE: And then we can see
you have a bunch of sines--
actually, in this case, you
have a bunch of cosine terms.
So you know that-- by having
the cosine terms, [INAUDIBLE]..
DENNIS FREEMAN: So you just
said something that seemed
to take a left turn, there.
What was the thing about series?
AUDIENCE: So if you
take your Fourier
series of a sum of cosines,
it's just the coefficient
of the same sign?
DENNIS FREEMAN: So,
that sounds good.
Could we use that idea of
taking a Fourier series
a little earlier in the proof?
How would I take the
Fourier transform of that?
Fourier series of that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: All 1's.
All 1's.
DENNIS FREEMAN: All
the 1's, yes, yes.
This is periodic.
It has a series.
Trick?
No, no, no-- clever
observation, not a trick.
So it's a periodic waveform.
It has a series.
OK, why is that good?
Periodic waveform series, I
only need to look at one period.
I reduce an infinite
number of impulses to one.
That's a good move.
So all I need to do is--
to find the series,
all I need to do
is think about the
Fourier series sum.
Which is almost the same
thing, except that now I've
got something that
has k's in it, right?
Because a series only
has harmonic frequencies.
So what I can do is,
instead of thinking
about a Fourier series--
so now I can say, instead of
finding the Fourier transform,
let's find the Fourier series.
That's find a sub k,
which would be 1 over t
to the integral on t of x
of t e to the minus j 2 pi
kt by t on t, OK?
So now I only need
to find the series.
And by integrating over t--
OK, well I'll do
the easy one, right?
Never do something that's hard.
I can choose any interval of t.
Let me take that one.
So the only thing
that persists, then--
so if I do minus--
whatever, t by 2 to t by 2,
then this becomes delta of t.
And delta of t sifts out
the 0 value of this guy.
But e to 0 is 1.
So this is 1 over t for all k.
We knew that, right?
The Fourier series for a
unit impulse is 1 everywhere.
All the harmonics
have the same size--
same size, same magnitude,
same phase everywhere.
Then, since we
know the series, we
can trivially convert it into
a Fourier transform, right?
Using the deep insight from
a few slides ago, right?
So how do you take a series
and turn it into a transform?
Substitute for every k.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Put an
impulse in place of every k
at the frequency-- omega--
that corresponds to that k, OK?
The k's-- 0, 1, 2, 3, are
the 0, 1, 2, 3 harmonics.
The harmonics are harmonics
of the fundamental.
The fundamental is 2 pi over t.
So you put one impulse
at every multiple of 2 pi
over capital T. And you
multiply them all by 2 pi.
So here's your answer.
You start with this
thing you recognize
as a periodic waveform.
You turn it into a series.
Then you convert every
one of the harmonics
into a continuous
frequency representation
so that the spacing is the
base period 2 pi over cap T.
The height of these
guys was 1 over T,
because of the annoying
1 over T factor in front
of the Fourier series formula.
And you get an extra 2 pi,
because the annoying 1 over 2
pi in the inverse
Fourier formula, OK?
So what we see, then, is
that the Fourier transform
of an impulse train
is an impulse train.
And so we can use that, then,
to find the Fourier transform
of this mass, remember?
Oh, I've got-- oh, here it is.
I was taking my
base waveform, which
was a triangle,
trying to figure out
what would happen if I did an
infinite extension of that--
an infinite periodic extension.
I think about the extension
as being convolving the base
waveform.
Cover that up.
If I think about convolving
the base wave, form--
oh, no, it's gone.
If I think about convolving
the base waveform
with periodic train
of impulses, that
means that-- so the
time waveform is
the convolution of two things.
That means that the
Fourier transform is
the multiplying of two things.
So I write down the transform
of the base waveform--
thing that we did
a long time ago.
I write down the Fourier
transform of the impulse train.
The period of the
impulse train is
the same as the period of
the periodic extension, which
is capital T.
It was 4.
So that means the
impulses are separated
by 2 pi over 4 pi over 2.
And the height of
the impulse is always
equal to their separation.
So they're also pi over 2.
So then all I do is
multiply this times this,
and that gives me the transform.
Convolving time,
multiplying frequency.
The important thing that
I found is that the effect
of periodic extension--
I took a base
waveform and turned it
into a string of
waveforms, right?
So over here, I
took a base waveform
and turned it into a repeated
thing, like so, in time.
The effect of the
periodic extension,
which we understand trivially
in time, is to sample frequency.
What I get in the frequency
representation is samples.
The samples being
controlled by how long
is the periodic extension.
So what I get is samples.
Instead of getting all of
these, I just get part.
I just get a uniformly-spaced
sample set separated by pi
over 2.
So then the effect of
the periodic extension
was to sample the Fourier
transform of the base waveform.
And that's the reason we can
think about the Fourier series
as being just a
sequence of numbers.
In fact, those
numbers are the same.
Or, they differ by 2 pi, right?
So I have to multiply
these guys by 2 pi
to get the Fourier
transform coefficients,
because the Fourier transform
of cosine of e to the j omega
not t, I should say,
is 2 pi delta, OK?
So the reason the Fourier
series coefficients
are related the way they
are, the reason they sample
the Fourier transform,
is because we
can regard the periodic
extension, which
was convolved by
an impulse train
as being equivalently
multiplying by an impulse
train and frequency.
OK?
That's what I wanted you to see.
I wanted you to see
that if you think
about periodic extension--
which is moving left
in this diagram.
If you think about moving
left, what you're really doing
is sampling in frequency.
So that's the reason it came out
having a sampled representation
on the left.
The periodic extension
convolving with an impulse
train was the same as
multiplying by the impulse
train and frequency, which
has the effect of sampling
the frequency response.
OK, so now the effect
of moving this way
was the same sampling
in frequency.
Well, what happens
if you actually
sample in time, which is
what you do when you go up?
It's got to be an
[INAUDIBLE] like this, right?
So, the most useful thing
about the Fourier transform
is that the Fourier
transform and the inverse
transform look almost the same.
That's the most useful
property of the transform.
Now, the Fourier transform has
a simple inverse relationship,
and is almost precisely the same
except for the annoying 2 pi
and except for a
change of sign--
e to the j omega t, compared
to e to the minus j omega t.
Except for those
trivial differences,
they're the same thing.
So we might expect that if we
understood the effect of moving
that way, which is convolve in
time, multiply in frequency,
you might expect an analogous
thing to happen this way.
And of course, it does.
So here, let's think
about the base waveform--
same base waveform.
But now what we're doing
is sampling in time.
And I'll just
arbitrarily, for the sake
of illustration, sample it
with capital T equals a half.
Question is-- what would
that sampling in time
do to the Fourier transform?
OK, sampling is time.
That's something we understand
completely in the time domain.
What would happen in
the Fourier domain?
OK, well that's a
little hard to compare,
because the domain of
these two signals--
this is continuous domain,
T. This is discrete domain.
And that's kind of annoying.
So it's kind of hard,
because they're not on equal
footing to compare them.
So what I can do is map
the same information
that was here into a
representation over here that
is continuous in time.
The information over
here was 0 everywhere,
except one half-and-half.
Here it's 0 everywhere
Anyone know why I used
impulses instead of just
making the function different?
Why didn't I, instead of using
the complicated-- wouldn't it
be much easier if I
didn't use the impulses?
And if instead, I just
said, OK, my xp of t--
why didn't I say xp of
t is almost everywhere
0, except at that point, at
that point, and at that point?
Why didn't I do that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Right, let's
assume that it is continuous.
And that there's exactly
three points that differ
from the straight line at 0.
Yes?
The integral's 0.
That never works.
In fact, the most
trivial representation
that only has energy at three
places is three impulses.
That's the only way to
get non-trivial energy.
OK, so I can't do that.
I'm forced to do
something like this.
So now the idea is--
I switched to this
kind of representation
that has the same information,
but has the same domain--
CT, continuous time.
So that now I can think
about-- what's the Fourier
transform of this guy?
Well, it's the same idea.
The way I can think
about computing
this thing from that thing is to
multiply in time by an impulse
train.
What's the effect of multiplying
time by an impulse train?
What's the effect in frequency?
Multiply in time by
an impulse train,
what are you doing to frequency?
Convolving frequency.
So we take the
original base waveform,
but now we convolve it.
And lo and behold, we
convolve this signal--
which could be anything-- with
this signal-- which is always
periodic.
If you convolve in anything with
a periodic, what do you get?
Periodic, inevitable.
So the fact that
I sampled in time
leads to periodic in frequency.
That's the point.
Sampling in time leads
to periodic in frequency.
That's always going to be true.
So we end up with a
relationship here.
The sampled waveform is
going to be periodic.
In here it's periodic, and 4 pi.
That's a little different
from what we've seen before.
If we had looked
at the x of n, we
would have seen something
that was periodic in 2 pi,
but that's because the
frequencies are different.
One
The first one I
showed is a function
of little omega, which has
the units radians per second.
This one is a function of cap
Omega, which has the units
radians, they're different.
One's frequency
in discrete time.
One's frequency in
continuous time.
And there's a relationship,
and that relationship
is always this.
That's the reason I write the
two frequencies differently.
One way to relate the two
frequencies is via sampling.
That's a way of taking
a continuous time signal
and turning it into a
discrete time signal.
When you do that, if you
sample by the sampling
interval capital
T, that dictates
that this relationship's
going to be like that.
And it's very general.
All you need to do is
look at the definitions.
If you look at the definition
of the DT Fourier transform--
that's this-- the CT Fourier
transform-- that's this--
and just remember that
we form this thing
by samples of that thing.
So now, if you think
about flipping the order--
and again, not worrying
about whether or not
it will converge.
You just assume it will
for the time being.
Just flip the order of the
summation and the integration.
This then sifts out the value
of little t equals n cap T,
and we get a formula for
the continuous time Fourier
transform that looks
just like the formula
for the discrete time
Fourier transform.
The only difference
in the two is that one
has discrete domain, n.
The other has
continuous domain, time.
And by sampling, we convert
continuous domain, time,
into discrete domain, n.
So we're always going to end
up with this relationship that
the discrete frequency--
that's generated by sampling--
the discrete
frequency is related
to the continuous frequency
multiplied by capital
T. Capital T has the
units of seconds.
So that takes radians per second
and turns it into radians.
OK, almost done, one more.
So I've gone from here to here.
What happens if I do
a periodic extension?
The answer was that
you convolve in time,
which is the same as
multiply in frequency
by an impulse train, which
is the same as sampling
in frequency.
Convolving time,
sampling frequency.
That's what happened
when I did this one.
I just now did this one.
What happens if
you sample in time?
Sample in time is multiplied
by an impulse train.
Multiplied by an impulse
train is the same as convolve
in frequency.
Convolve in frequency
makes it periodic.
Sample in time,
periodic in frequency.
The last example is just
to do this direction.
What happens if I
take the DTFT and try
to turn that into a DTFS?
Not surprisingly,
what I have to do
is the same thing I
did in continuous time.
If I want to change
this DT signal-- which
is aperiodic-- into
a periodic DT signal,
I do periodic extension.
I can think about the
periodically-extended waveform,
here extended by
multiples of 8, as being
the original waveform convolved
with that unit sample train.
And so if I convolve by
the unit sample train, what
do I do in frequency?
Convolve by unit
sample train in time,
gives [INAUDIBLE] and frequency.
Multiply-- so I'm expecting
that the answer will be sampled,
and that's what happens.
So I take the Fourier
transform of this case.
Which, like all
Fourier transforms,
is periodic in 2 pi.
And now I think
about convolving it
with this unit
sample train, which
has the same relationship
as the impulse train.
And the impulse
train-- the train
of impulses separated
by capital T, turned
into a train of impulses
separated by 2 pi over t.
Here separated by capital
N, turns into impulse trains
separated by 2 pi over n--
same thing.
So if this is 8
over here, I do 2 pi
over 8, which is pi over 4.
So convolving in
discrete time is the same
as multiplying by this
impulse train, which gives me,
then, a string of samples
from that waveform.
So the effect of
going this way, which
is periodic extension, which is
the same as convolving in time,
is sampling in frequency.
OK, so the idea,
then, is that that's
a way of rationalizing how
the Fourier series would
have worked.
So the Fourier series was
a discrete set of numbers
exactly for that reason.
I started out with
something that
was continuous in
frequency, but I sampled it
because I was multiplying
by an impulse train.
So what I hope this
did, OK, was dragged you
through a couple of examples
that will make things
a little bit easier tomorrow.
But I also hope
that you understand
how we went from a
diagram that looks kind
of complicated an arbitrary--
here we had DT on the
top and CT on the bottom,
periodic on the left and
not periodic on the right.
The transforms had all that
things turn 90 degrees.
We ended up with discrete on
the left instead of on the top,
and we ended up with
periodic in the top
rather than on the left.
And that's entirely because
of the relationships
between the various
Fourier transforms.
So the idea is--
and you can understand
all of those relationships
by simply thinking
about impulse trains.
We take an aperiodic signal,
turn it into a periodic
by convolution in time, which
is the same as multiplying
frequency, which is
the same as sampling.
We sample in time by multiplying
by an impulse train, which
is the same as
convolving in frequency,
which makes it periodic.
So the hope is that this
looks like more than just--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8--
eight independent equations,
they're not.
It's really two equations--
the transform and the inverse
transform-- and they're
almost the same equation,
except for taking into
account the special properties
of the different domains.
OK, have a good time,
and see you tomorrow.